welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and today
I'm in Manchester I'm joined by for
though you can't see that Louise who I'm
with just yeah so I'm joined by Louise
McMullen who is the MD of a business
called white label recruitment please
thanks for joining me well always like
to start
how did Louise enter the world of
recruitment please do share talk to us
how did that happen I didn't fall into
recruitment so it's not conventional
stories where people just stumble across
it and I left college at 17 and didn't
know what wanted to do but I knew I
wanted to run a business of some sort
really yeah so yeah basically dropped on
many levels because I was being like me
forced into playing for applications and
deciding what you want to do when I was
like I've got no idea
no just the college and I I just got
really good grades and I don't actually
know what degree I want to do so yeah
I'm definitely not gonna just go home
you know choose a uni when I wasn't sure
so in previous to that I'd works for my
dad
and he's in his business so I had a chat
with him and I was pretty upset and I
was like I just don't want to go to uni
yet so my dad said right you can come
and work with me again
so it was 17 I went anyway they've got
like oh you still got it in a five-place
business i play five place I see lovin
age and so I went there I thought routes
gonna get ahead together for a year it's
work out and I'll just be a bit delayed
so did that and basically ended up in
Angela six years really yeah would you
do that so I've just ended up running
the business with my dad really yeah and
then I got into him obviously I was
earning quite a lot of money and stuff
for my age and I'm like oh my god I
can't really go back to uni now and work
everything out and
then yeah that was it really then I got
contacted by and a friend in recruitment
that saw sort of what I was doing and
how ambitious I wasn't everything and he
got me an interview and that was it
really
yeah so what did you have a friend
immigrant yeah so what that's pretty
interesting then so would you say what
you the decision you made working with
that that exposures really helped you
now oh my god yeah that's crazy that
like a hundred percent okay I ended up a
blur since they see over like yeah I
really trying to help him like have a
better work-life balance really yeah he
was working like six days a week seven
days a week and then was like a brick
and mortar business and then you know
you just it was really manual and stuff
like that and then I try to like get it
into the 21st century in like news
website updated and marketing and when I
took over the sales started earning
Commission yeah and my aim was like for
him to work last night over yeah and
then I just had a friend who who who saw
what I was doing any just said I think
you just could really couldn't week
Reitman movie and I was waiting for this
opportunity but I didn't know what it
was
you felt like no waiting for something
in all these years I'm like I knew I'm
not gonna say that but I didn't know
yeah what I was gonna day for him so
yeah just got it got me an interview
it's a may and how did your friend cell
recruitment be honest aim it's like
running your own business okay aim money
yeah
I'm bit you know ambitious people you
can like run your own business but got a
support of another company yeah sounds
like it just sounded like perfect for me
and it just got me out of that so I've
role that I was in and but then
obviously when I went into the interview
I was I was definitely not a person that
should be in recruitment really had no
degree when you did yeah you need a
degree I dropped out of college a lot
good and worked a lot of six years there
so I it just didn't on paper lot that
great mmm but obviously yeah you get
food interview instead of like that so
it was alright okay
yeah so and then you ended up at is it
wasn't Huxley yeah and they're correct
there are they part of a big brand
that's always part of estimators that
was where my friend work yeah got some
interviews or other companies as well
yeah I'm just like make a comparison so
I did loads of research on it
and I was like god this is like perfect
for me like this is exactly what
wouldn't know I was designed I did
research on yeah as I because again my
friend told me about and I was like ah
yeah this is like really in line with
cuz I just did sales at that point when
I wanted to just get better at sales and
I research into recruitment was like you
know what more face to face more
consultative yes what I really like
that's what I need to add to myself yeah
what what did you like when you
researched it cuz it's interesting to
research and we see like the 360 side of
it like you get you get a job on no one
get the job and then you follow through
with the whole process and then you
build relationships and the your your
clients I collect that whole concept of
it and I think it was only 360 that was
about then anyway I don't think there's
any other options but there was a lot of
variety in changing days will be
different going out on your meetings
like out the office one day when you're
going back and so many different aspects
the job but I've like multitasking and
stuff like that so I was like okay
sounds good why did you pick that's free
well I knew someone in there which is
always good and but I just like via the
lights the business lights or looking
about a obviously the holidays that was
a big attraction really at the time only
my dad works for my dad for like six
years
shopping Manchester yeah I'd say like so
let's sort of have that culture oh god
yeah like the culture was just like
amazing
obviously the training aspect it was
like ridiculous
let's go to London for like the week and
constant training and massive on that
sassed off and I really liked the
managers like my manager who taught me
on was just really gelled with her what
model is you going
supply chain supply chain which was yeah
which was pretty easy as well so I kind
of really I couldn't get that pretty
quickly so then obviously since starting
white label what market you did now did
that did you start so I was putting on
an engineering permanent team so like
they did design quality supply chain say
old I think supply chain but I mean
engineering so I we now label do
engineering as well okay similar markets
okay so for everyone's benefit then see
how long did you work at s3 for it's
only 18 months really yeah then you've
been running why they're partly and I've
been running this business now for eight
years
oh yes yeah okay yeah eighteen months
then I'm starting an equipment business
sorry baby yeah yeah that how would you
always like to speak to people about
that first 12 months in recruitment
they're there can't be really difficult
for a lot of people was sounding
difficult for myself
how are your first time at some
equipment they were fine really really
easy got a bit lucky I don't know but
basically when I went into that business
if you had such sort of got tea in Milan
the engineering Pantene was like
incredible and what made it more the
people they just recruited the right
people right the right culture the right
personality fits the right drives I've
one of the reason why they were there
we've all similar ages and we just got
it right whatever they did they got that
that's he might so it was hard to not
really do well mmm everyone shared
information everyone had their own
particular really really nice tea and
and it makes a massive difference that
you didn't try to know no one's toes or
anything and you wanted to do well for
you team so we've passed jobs about we
just give each other candidates and just
a good experience I act like I think in
my first I remember like my first two
weeks someone just took me out and meet
him a mate Chris taught me to a client
gave me a job and I went back and I
filled it even like a week so I was
really an aside like sorts of good start
so I really this is meant like yeah the
crew
I had a good age good name
a good start a very good star so it gave
me that sort of positive so I mines that
I know that horses yeah really good
market way too technical
[Laughter]
yes Cooksley yeah yeah white label is
payment contracts I've never really been
a contract Bilodeau but you put them in
that perm
yeah yeah yeah okay dude just quit on
that point it'd be good to because I'm
sure obviously your early experience and
what you experiencing that team and what
you've went really well that you've sort
of brand here and yeah I mean that's a
lie
what what do you think were some of the
biggest contributors to that that team
just making you feel like that and you
know I mean what was some of the the big
things that you think contributed to
that team doing so well and why it works
so well it hooks like they recruited
people based on certain competences and
and certain values I think I don't think
heard for actually understood what the
values were at that point or go get it
now well I was there it was enthusiasm
just like positivity like very resilient
driven ambitious people
everyone knew why they were they have
and what they were doing it for so even
if they didn't want a career in
recruitment like long tape yeah you
could chats people and you'd know why
they were working so hard and really
chat about it loads on nights out and
stuff which is really clear that
everyone they knew I felt like my team
ah yeah it was really really Claire and
and I told you interested yeah I've also
happy for each other everyone was
genuinely happy for each other like yeah
it was it was good it's interesting yeah
so I've tried to do that here like he
definitely does work okay anything else
how first 12 months and it seems like
you just absolutely know you know I'm in
work for me was it was a huge learning
curve like I'd not been see universities
or denied that so I have appreciation
for being like group situations and all
of that stocks that was
really knew and never ever not client in
my life on my own so I have to learn all
that pretty quickly I think that's quite
tough but they give you such good
training so what made it so good a lot
of people who said this on this patrol
plays really massive role plays and we
do that hey like mo is really good with
that shawl
she'll sit in the room and she'll do it
at the desk and just get people in there
in the zone and like push them out of
comfort zone it's horrible or plausible
or horrible absolutely horrible I
remember being in like Mia means and it
put you on the spot and it's like going
dead ratch like oh my gosh don't know
what to say it's horrible but you do
need that's like the push my comfort
zone like little Wow
yeah yeah so I think even though as a
rookie it's really tough you need you
need a company to push you push the
boundaries a little bit but it wasn't
sort of too intense it was just enough I
think well yeah I found that hard find
the clients heart I found going on a
meeting hard even just like getting my
car and driving down motorways I've not
really done before it's only that you go
to a business like getting a car and go
though and then do do like a bit to get
myself at yeah only like 22 23 no no
it's quite a lot too yeah yeah I always
remember my first client meeting with my
old boss and it is really cool is a
really cool experience cool fill in as
long yeah got a proper job yeah you see
what yeah look in the park do you know
no you're right it is and then when you
do that first meeting on your own it is
a good experience without a boss then
don't yes and like God like I've just
got in this engineering business not an
MD mmm of like told them what a day
they've given me an exlusive job I'm
gonna go back and do a really good job
on it and you just feel really well just
like a cycle but yeah I found that quite
tough like really challenging but
obviously you've put a brave face on oh
how did you be on your first year mate
how how did you build in your first year
it was 250 really yeah I don't know yeah
no that's decent yeah first year yeah
okay well I threw that that's really
good it was really good I can't really
take a lot credit as well because we I
told you we had a good team we passed a
lot of business and we shared
information stuff like that each of us
talked each other are narrow I mean so
we worked really clever really clever
and really smart so it wasn't like 250
where I got all the new business then
yeah I think one actually did the
numbers it was 60% money business and
40% for my team really yeah in the first
one month yeah
so as good as 5% came what users and
that it was gosh mm a thousand oh yeah
and then I think it was a recession was
maybe I just laughed I think okay yeah
dive into sort of the more recent
experience yeah because like a lot of
people that listen to this podcast kind
of quite early on in their career yeah
and like obviously do you think your
experience now implement people here hmm
what are you talking to people about
doing 250k now do you know I mean no no
no yeah however like what would you say
was the biggest I mean you probably
mentioned it a lot but was the biggest
contributor you think I'm such a good
start and that's a nice thick working I
work at it was like totally different to
most people's aim I would get on with my
job mess about don't talk a lot ready
aim really focus got my head down I'm
really focused I would be in it 7 leave
it I was left a left on time because I
lights my sort of time after work and
see flight that bike got in quite early
which was dead time to me anyway
interesting about ok and just get all my
kpi's done I before anyone got in so I
ever want to be walking in over like yes
do my mail shot
really I did my contact where'd that
come from that work ethic I've worked
with my dad fair since I was like 14
so I've waited six days a week since
like 14 to 23 yes to me going to in an
office third player Stephanie moaning
was like pretty easy weight lifting
anything lifting you know what Fair Play
how how many 23 year olds have worked
six days a week for like what six seven
years ass absolutely
set him fireplace and I know that as a
graph mate yeah move them all as well by
the way really moved a mile Wow lift it
nothing that I feel like from the sound
of it like that that was the best union
you could have picked do you know I mean
I know we always know it's like it's
pretty boring at times but like the
stuff you do you learn from me and like
resilience and like getting free boredom
so when you get really bored and you
just got like crack on like everything
like recruitment can get a bit boring
sometimes it'll sink well it's
definitely annoying it was badass at
like I've got all people around me and
like you got like dead good atmospheres
and targets and stuff like that so it's
not that difficult it's got through bad
day really okay yeah the conversation
again recently and I know you'll see
you're big on well unbalanced well-being
these sorts of things
yeah I particularly not see our world
recruitment I think so the conversation
to give you context was the chap that I
did a podcast with recently James he
basically said that each CEO went there
he asked and asked them sorry ask them
what's the biggest contributor to or
what do you think is the best thing or
what big bill has always happened it was
always working oh really there's always
work ethic but I feel like in today's
world when you say work ethic yeah do
you know I mean it's it's got that okay
well as you said you're here from 7:00
to 7:00 yeah not really sexy no no no no
you know I mean now so how what what's
your view on work ethic in 2019 2020
yeah so maybe I've not explained that
right so even though I did get in
early on a lot of days that didn't
really contribute to building that much
money like getting in an hour earlier
four days three or four days a week it's
not gonna make you a 250k bill it was
what I was doing and in the time I was
there which was the normal eight nine
hour - yeah I think for me you work at
it is doing what you need to do when you
need to do it yeah and I think weeks
where you know stuff is going really
well you don't need to be in the office
or seventh or seven but I think when you
do need to put it in you do need to put
it in and when you like you say there's
so many talents eat watch people and
watch what they're doing you think
you're wasting so much time yeah you put
your hair but you're not really present
so right you know what I mean you can
watch what people are doing anything god
you could have got over five yeah what
you tell you I think that I was just
interested to get your thoughts on that
because I believe in that much work in
our worse anyway don't think work ethic
means someone who's done more hours in
somewhere else it's back to you it's
back to your point my just did seven to
seven nothing that has no know that the
equation is a knife you at seven to
seven that means you're gonna bill more
no it doesn't now if you are doing seven
to seven and you're doing all the right
activities look then definitely did you
get on your ballot that's the thing when
people again mixed up isn't it and
that's what you're talking about yeah
it's like you have to work effort you're
just willing to do what you need to do
yeah time required and when you may not
be feeling like it but you do it yeah
and for me as well where the work I
think is doing your work when you don't
well you just said it yeah when you
don't feel like doing it when you've had
that bad day or you tired or you think I
really want to be somewhere else but
you're making those little decisions all
the time to get you out you need to go
something with me yeah I was so wide so
I'm into like reading all about self
stuff and all that yeah there's a guy
called Grant Cardone yeah yeah yeah yeah
so something he said something that's
always read resonated with me
when I was in recruitment and it really
helped mean it was like you've got a
love what you know other people hate
doing like if you like what if you if
you love what you don't like doing yeah
like if you really love it yeah and you
but you don't enjoy doing it yeah it's a
lot for me it was if I actually had the
mindset of light right if I actually
really start to actually really enjoy
and love making cold calls even though I
don't really like yeah that's gonna
massively help yeah we got taught
something in the Frog eat the Frog yeah
so could we do it in air so we're like
right what's she working on your day
plan yeah what do you not like doing so
yeah eat the frog and you come in and
like write what's what
I think I hate the most or something
that's really gonna take my brain power
and the frog and you come in and like
right what's what's the thing I hate the
most
or something that's really going to take
my brain power and do that fair slice
yeah eat the frog a lot basically it's
basically like a rock so my dad's sharp
used to come in
yeah places really don't I could sit in
my office and let do the sales yeah
which is what I like doing so just get
the worst thing out the way in the
morning it's a rookie or a manager or
team leader I just face up to the stuff
that you don't want to do yeah you
people don't do mail shots for example
so come in and you know write you real
good mail shot and then you can be free
to do the rest of your day then-current
yeah yeah nothing that that is actually
a really good tactic just to crack on
with wood yeah because it's such a good
feeling once you've done that yeah you
know I mean yeah so I mean you said at
the beginning see have you always wanted
to have your own business then really
yeah however when I first went into
recruitment that sort of starts because
I loved it I loved it Huxley yeah
absolutely loved it and and it gave that
role gave me the feeling that I was
really my own business even though you
work for someone else but that was fine
you didn't really feel that no ending it
felt like you know you like said before
I got on your meetings and you doing
stuff to go home and maybe post about
first and then write your day plan for
the next day of what you wanted to do so
and it was like running your own
business and the only B's and I ended up
leaving was because I
I had a baby so otherwise I probably
would have stayed there maybe one day I
would've look to doing it myself but it
wasn't really on the radar at the time I
would do if wanted to like build a team
and maybe become a director or something
yeah studs I he was well nearly one
really yeah yeah yeah but it was a bit
of a way away a time for me because I
didn't really cope with the having a
baby thing very well really no so I had
like a bit of it felt like really
anxious I was horrible really horrible
feeling what disavow gorgeous no it was
nothing it was nothing specific it was
just a feeling you're like yeah shaking
and just like didn't feel like I could
cope very well and I went back to where
hooks let off like we're back to work
into VF and I just sort of went into a
bit of a meltdown I just came out of
nowhere like a little mini panic attack
really yeah it was horrible and I just
looked on the office thinking oh my god
like if I don't build anywhere near as
much like I'm not gonna be looked so I'm
in a good way and put this stupid
pressure on myself and no one at the
time I just kids named the creep Minh as
much it's ten years ago so yeah and I
just felt like a bit of a loner
I mean I thought gosh like my life is
gonna be so different even though we
actually never ended up being any
different but I'm so yeah I felt like I
don't have enough in another choice
really so it was came out of necessity
really mmm
but yes I felt like had this like bit of
a meltdown it's all about going into a
few other places that don't know me so
I've not got this big 252 I'm had and
then I couldn't get an interview really
anywhere no no and no one would give me
an interview I've got loads of telephone
interviews but because it was like I
wanted a four day week and then I said
right well I'll build I'll commit to a
150 target like that's it
um I don't feel like I even know if I
could do any more than that because I've
never done a four-day week I've never
maybe before so no and then everyone on
my telephone it feels like what makes
you think you can do that you've never
done a four-day week and the time like
no one was really doing it yeah totally
um so I'm confidence for just like
totally knocks it was horrible yeah like
that that feelings that you feel of
being anxious it was awful
yes so I was like to know what I haven't
actually got an eruption it I was backed
into a corner a little bit and so I
thought I I'll just try it and say
Albert so how long yeah sorry yeah
Avia and how many of you are there and
17:17 about yeah I mean thank you so
much that you've learned through this
yeah ed so how many children do you have
now just free see that's good you've had
two more children
yeah since run in white lame yeah Jesus
Christ no one was so I guess firstly
let's just start there'll be people
listening the yeah I definitely think
about starting our own recruitment
business yeah
what should they be thinking about that
sort of that maybe you didn't realize or
think about when white label was formed
what should what's your advice to people
thinking about Stan and cream in
business invest in yourself for anyone
else so I would say just make sure
you've got some sort of network or hmm
some sort of membership to have hair
group or something like you can talk to
people and that I've done it because
you'll save yourself yes yeah problems
invest in yourself yeah so like that you
know would you mean brother just like
you know your networking groups you can
go to some of them charge you certain my
money I'm on the two part of it and but
you go to you know once a month go meet
or the directors of recruitment
companies might like one-man bands or
people who've got five people laugh
people who've got 20 or 50 for that for
me that's just price of a realism gym
membership or something yeah anything
else it's really lonely really found
that really lonely and when did you hire
someone
we were yerin yeah well yeah you had one
person yeah yeah so it was yes quite
it's quite lonely work from home which
is sometimes not great for you mental
health and you like what they call no I
only do it now because in one day do one
day at home and technically it's not at
home I go to I go it's like a coffee
shop I would pop up something like that
yeah yeah and take a laptop and just do
all mountain mean and like my thinking
time but obviously when you build in a
recruitment business you're building and
stuff like that so and you're setting
your house it's quite quite lonely I
think you don't if you're doing
something are you
yeah so you might get like I don't know
a question on terms and you think what
did you actually know what they would
you to do I had a friend from in my
husband's friend who's got a recruitment
business okay and oh my god like he
helped me so much absolutely pretty much
really
yeah yeah you could just really so I
speak to him now like really I got stuck
I think he's done it for about double
that was about really lucky that we had
that relationship oh so someone doesn't
pay you or you get a complain and if you
like that's not so few deal with when
you're working for an agency yeah like
maybe what do I do now can you recommend
a lawyer how do I get this client to
page and
taking someone on like you might take
someone on and then they leave all you
need to dismiss them for whatever reason
and what's the process for that what
we're just believe you've never done it
and you know where do you finance has
come from mmm is about you know you
write that on LinkedIn I need an invoice
factoring company and you'll get about
500 messages values your absolute how
did you even know what question of
swaths yeah no we use the right one mmm
so for me yeah mentor always a good a
good one as well so I had that without
even sort of looking for it but if you
starting out try and find one mmm and
even if that's someone that has invested
in your business a lot a bit mmm even if
they're getting something out of it
person or something like that that's
that that's having someone that you can
speak to about what you're doing about
their stuff is super yeah when it's
rather than this you in your living room
don't we need today cuz I think you
spend so much time questioning your own
mmm sanity as well questioning yourself
and you've gone from being a really high
Billa usually people who set up to being
in a room on your own when old people
mmm
trying to build again with no clients
and not one sortie so it's like it's
pretty big did you did you know from the
beginning that you wanted to grow it to
like say it was out a necessity at the
time it was like a fight or flight for
me yeah and then it was only when I got
got sorry from about myself back on my
feet again like mentally and something
like that that sort of time and stuff
became clear and then I got my drive
back again and I was like you know yeah
this this is my thing again though
you're saying they're like again invest
in yourself and yeah I guess what you're
saying there is yeah mate if you are if
you are thinking about growing a
business will ever make sure you're
doing it when you're in a good place
yeah I don't know cuz I don't know how
people start businesses because I think
people do it for a lot of different
reasons I think
sometimes I've been something quite
negative really drive yet for that
school doesn't what I've always be the
driver does it do you think do you think
people like thinking about starting
recruitment business
I should know from day one if they want
to grow it to like 10 or 15 know or
should it be a lifestyle business like I
think they should be open I only feel
now that this is really getting traction
okay and I don't know how you would know
that unless you are a certain type of
person do you meet a lot of people who
do you know that
yeah from day one however I'm not a lot
of men so I think maybe there's a bit of
difference because I've always known
I've wanted a family and I've never
known how that's all gonna pan out so I
think for a man that I'll correct me if
I'm wrong but they don't usually stay at
home with babies and stuff like that so
they can plan things out I'd be easier
than say a woman caught because they've
never got to do the maternity leave and
they've not gets off back to work or if
you're a woman who owns a recruitment
company
you gotta get cover some coffee rolls so
I feel like it's been harder to plan out
any more kids it goes oh yeah it's
actually it's quite easy totally good
that no it means or not maybe on that
note
first year children mum if trying to
build a recruitment business yeah what
was that like one go is going back to
the hours again really was actually like
they're like did that mean that you've
got less children no so I do get off
normal day document nursery go to work
go home I'll come to the office after
your why and do you know all day go home
duty I had a lot of family that helped
me out and stuff and I used to go and
play my sports in stuff like that a
couple of times a week get back in the
zone and then get him back in bad and
then I'll do 9:00 till 2:00 in the
morning so I thought I reckon for two
years
really yeah yeah yeah no I liked it
really like who's good could you like
you're building something so it's like
wasn't like work
mmm it was like and also like 2:00 in
the morning
noble in the 2:00 in the morning they
add me and like between all my documents
in like what I'm gonna do and you know
prep your mail charts in you know I got
quite a buzz off it but also you've
gotta know when you're coming in like
you can't think often I write this month
I'm like I think like six months ahead
so I'm always a bit of a planner yeah
I'm like I I need to if I had a sniff of
a job I would be shortlisted people so
that as people the next day straightaway
to be carly and something like that but
i am go for me I'm all about like
building the park from quite stable
person okay I'm not mom - mom / no I
actually love the honesty there on yeah
yeah hours you have to do I have to
because I was like I have to get enough
money to felicity yeah just be
sustainable and how yeah good whoring
your first person yeah anyone that's
gone through that process yeah would you
do anything differently like what would
if I'm in the price is now thinking
about hiring the first person for my
business so long ago but what comes to
mind it's like if you would speak to
someone right now like Louise I'm
thinking about hiring the first class
for my recruitment business would you
say anything to me black ain't gon make
sure that they understand the
relationship and how it's gonna change
okay and so that first person comes in
they're like part of your business in
danger and then ask you business grows
and you develop yourself as a yeah Billa
recruitment owner
business owner to a manager to a
director and that relationship starts
changing and I think it's quite
difficult for those people at first come
in to accept that change over a certain
period of time so if I was to do
anything differently I would have maybe
tried to explain that that change was
gonna work getting themselves in for a
yeah and the relationship the
relationship is a big one it changes so
much
hmm so I know a lot people leaves first
person that could have come in I've not
necessarily got into a management roles
but then it's caused a lot of problems
in businesses because they might think
because of the first one in that they're
entitled to bowl they might have to not
be suited to that position that made
sense
aim yeah okay that's quite a big one so
how long have you been around the sort
of 1517 mark like has that what's that
journey been this year has been a big
one for growth because and my she's like
kind of like a business partner now
where she was been promoted to director
has come back off maternity and she's
grown the business quite a lot this year
so frozen I think we've talked on five
people ish a really yeah
and that's been I covered her last year
on her maternity and we grow up we took
two or three and the year before really
it's been in the last couple years
really
we've always been around the eight mark
the way I didn't say I work for as a run
that is what I mean me and that my old
boss had a really open relationship and
that was it was difficult to get past
that yeah yeah one thing that's
difficult now and your processor is
instructure yeah so I've been really
it's been a lot slower for us the growth
but I'm more about the foundation and
making sure everything's right before I
do something I need to say the end today
it's like it's people's lives you can't
be bringing people in and they've not
got a target to me or they don't know
where the next promotion is going from
so I've done it a lot of slower so that
the Foundation's there but now it's
there it's it's rocketed like it could
take I don't know so many people are now
but there's no job specs in places these
roles there's different promotions what
you say it makes up the foundation then
for people hundreds done yeah well but
what makes that for people listening
what what should what should people
really make sure they have in place or
the building blocks have in place if
they really want to start really good
like financials sort of backing in terms
of if you're going to use a factor
company you know you can get paid
quickly if you really need it get
yourself in a good credit position right
you got can get an overdraft if
something happens
everyone's got good job descriptions you
know exactly how your commission works
what commission structure very
transparent with everything you've got a
good training provider that everyone
goes through everyone's the same
good management program and everyone
goes to the same management program so
I'll you teen leaders are on the same
page and where you're gonna be based
what's your culture mmm why'd you do it
like all that took me a long time to
work it all out
really so yeah what she why I dunno why
I mean it took me years so at this out
like a long time why do things taking in
quality yeah I just didn't know really
yeah being honest and you know now yeah
yeah just didn't know what it was
so how did you find that out was that
was that like that's not easy it's
really not Wow what why why did you do
that Louise I did a conference call with
Mike Smith so he use the XM that hooks
up and he's 41 zap our - sod and as part
of that he did like a three-hour Carl
with me and he really started grilling
me on stuff and he's like why do you
what'd you do and I wrote it all down I
was like I really like making people
better I like seeing people progress I
like building something like process and
all these different things I've done all
over these years and he was like how can
you put that into words and I was like
it doesn't sound that good today sounds
of it yeah it doesn't sound like Holly's
huge vision statement so when I was on
the websites instead offering and he was
like but that's what it is and I was
like oh yeah it is actually
and since I've just accepted that like
it's actually really easy I like making
people better really it's like quite
simple but in all these years that's
what I've been building
I'd never knew what it was do you know -
yeah why'd you again why but why did why
why is that helped you why is that
helping you now
I mean why is that important for people
listening to really think about that and
now that down because you cannot have
good days every day so you've gotta have
to accept that you can have like really
bad days or you know things are not
going to go your way so if you know what
the bigger picture is and what you've
ease them for being here is you'll can
just brush it off a little bit off you
know excuse your perspective doesn't it
yeah yeah what those bigger picture is I
think I don't know it's a bit of a it's
a weird like it's a weird thing to sort
of know yeah hard I know it means
articulate but this time Internet box
good yeah oh yeah oh really I seen that
no this is interested is interested and
what what's been the most challenging
thing for you run and run in this
business having children so what do you
Madison know what to say that but then
at the same time if it didn't do it I
wouldn't be where I am so it's a bit
what you think that's been the huge
reason why it's such a good company as
well really yeah and they always say
don't they like your biggest talent ends
up being like yeah why would you mean oh
because you forced into you forced into
plans he forced into and walk into the
future forced into making decisions with
people's careers and how he most step-up
hugely so like the two years I had off
was the two years where my whole team of
steps what massively really and then
last year Emma and a few years on well
yeah one was like six months and then I
was off a bit more than and then knew
that you was a full year how I know this
is what I mean like so you how did you
manage that I'm really I I'm really
really trusting in people but like I
said before because the foundation so
that it wasn't that difficult mmm so you
technologies there your processes are
there you're you recruit the right
people that trust those trusts I
honestly can honestly tell you can ask a
ministers Welsh all very far yet
I was so adamant that she was like so
she was lead and I wanted to just give
her that chance we had one call for a
week every week for an hour that's it
that was it and then we did one monthly
review in a coffee shop really and then
I went on tops
I just wanted to like hard to know what
if I'm gonna have a business that's
gonna give me the life I want this has
got to work
so if it doesn't this isn't really what
I want to do because I can't sustain
being a mom working this March from if
I've got to be there all the time
because you're not sustainable you're
gonna pay an hour and how so for me it
was like a bit of a test like I told you
know and then and and also as well when
you put that much trust in people and
you delegate effectively and you give
them that chance and you trust them
people's people so good at the job like
the guys in hair do things so much
better than I do
they're so good at what they do and it
gives a chance just on that something
that's there'll be people listening that
probably know that they do want that
life where yeah they're not always
having to be involved but they're yeah
suppose my old boss is definitely that
yeah like if I was to say to you you
were talking about there but if I was to
say to you like some real practical
advice for people that can feel like
[ __ ] I'm still so involved about but I
don't want to be like how how can I
really start taking a step towards that
do you know I mean cuz that's amazing
that you did that yeah obviously when I
planned my second child name it was
obviously nine-month process you know we
made a plan you actually put plans yeah
you can't just obviously do it overnight
so we'd look it every week or every
month what part of my role can I mean
I'll be learning and doing on-the-job
training things like that just put a
little bit of time aside so it don't see
it as such a huge step so by the time it
actually came to happening she was
already doing the job anyway that's
really small that's really that's really
does
and so actually so basically of what you
started to do is actually over that
period like really like just build up
what you're doing a weekly basis okay
Emma or whoever it is in your business
like let's start here why don't you
start doing this continue to build and
building and I just had bothered yeah
you left yeah that's really interesting
and then they now mo now does that with
her team so these two or three different
people now that she replicates that with
yeah and she'll do that on a weekly not
always a weekly basis but you know
they'll always be some sort of training
whether learning something and we try to
explain this in the business that by
giving something away from it doesn't
mean that you're losing it you you're
you're growing yeah some way do you know
what you know what I mean so and give it
to team because like your bookies want
to be involved in doing sales days and
things like I'm you might be a team
leader to think you know I really love
this part of the job or the minute you
delegate that they become God and you
can focus on some your high level stuff
and so yeah we're just quite big on that
with constantly how teaching each other
eyeballs have you got a barrier trust in
people that's not easy that hire the
right people would you business what the
things that people must have trust what
you mean so you've got to hire people
you can trust so you need something and
I don't know you def I can I don't do
these interviews anymore questions that
you might ask them about you know things
that they've done at work or how would
you handle this situation and you can
usually tell in an interview if you give
them like a couple of chances to Isis I
think any like key characteristics that
you that these people have to have for
you that gives them the best possible
chance of because obviously just a
highlight here you know how many people
have left your business in the last five
years
not many I don't know I mean that's not
lost anyone in the last this is our
third yeah pretty good that yeah
and you know I mean so like there's
definitely faster than that yes like
what things do you always make sure or
really make sure that you're confident
these people have for you too
if we feel like someone is gonna step on
someone to get somewhere
yeah if they've give any indication of
our an example that's a good thing there
would be enough straight without even
question but there was a tune to Carmela
like and and that's quite easy to find
out because you can just ask confidence
based questions around you you know give
me a time when you know something's not
gone your way but it would have
benefited you and see what they say yeah
and we can happen if you don't endorse
it in ten minutes because we were just
no and obviously the I know it I hate
saying it but like the resilient thing
yeah
that's massive in a long interview for
that though so again we ask we try to
ask them things outside of work
really yeah he's never been results that
as like a last resort if it's in work
but what if you don't outside of work so
you know a time where you found
something really hard outside of work
and then specifically what was that how
did it feel what did you Dave he was
there it's in the Carl I you know so
it's not just a pre yes we use them
comfort it's called now the gold one and
really gorgeous that gives us so
someone's not recently that that was a
big thing for them they started doing
that like eighteen months yeah a big
impact yes we use that it final stage
what is there has there been my new
trainer that's more when I say all side
like that's sort of what are they going
to be sort of afraid of in this on the
sales side gives you a much more
questions you can go back inside
yeah it's really good actually that and
okay then back to the interviewing team
player in again I take that over take
someone with like that mentality that
was a rookie that I knew was exactly the
right person for our team over someone
who's been in recruitment five years
after
- umbrella mmm any - just yeah yeah at
last how you can obviously get the
attraction move people stay in for a
long time and not leaving and okay and
then the work ethic is a big one
again we really promote we're life
balance so don't get that confused
because I think sometimes it might come
across like oh you know I've got an
amazing way at life balance that might
label but we've worked really hard on me
I'm really committed to the team and
badman so everything's about the team
everything's about you know working
together and that is what I mean by him
sort of that exists what does that mean
to you and what does that look like
because that's clearly something you're
passionate about
yeah people in the monastery the work
and know you and your brand this clearly
something you're passionate about but
what does that mean to you from your and
your in your perspective for me when I
had that feeling of not being able to go
back to my job that I lost because I was
so scared of targets yes and yeah and
feeling like I love something so much
but I didn't feel like my wife was gonna
let me do it I got really like
passionate about not making the people
feel like yeah yeah yeah that Mason
don't know what it was it just like a
bit of a change and so I've always been
quite passionate like I don't like
seeing people struggle in yeah and
because if something at home mmm that's
affecting the way because I've one's got
the chance to do really well okay one
goes to work 9:00 to 5:00 and can do can
do the job but a lot of time its
external factors that contribute to for
sure
poor billion are good billion yeah and
some quite passionate that everyone's
got the same shot at the goal but just
sometimes everyone's got different
different things like oh boy you might
help them out with with stores over
everyone
balance for everyone is individually yes
so you can't just say oh well everyone
loves flexibility because some people
don't really know about it some people
actually make some worse mmm
some people need it some people just
need a break you not be you know not be
on the case all day about something and
how have you gone about finding out what
makes people tick then it comes back to
this the why because and yeah so I think
now everyone in the business understands
out done loads of training on it and
watched videos and stuff like that
well now that's what their wires yes
they have to write this at the start of
the reason yes they have to tell us what
it is any constant development so we as
managers need to know exactly what their
way is for any one time
I don't even manage anyone in that but I
would know yeah Drive someone so that I
can tap into what it is and it's not
manipulative or anything like it's just
about what motivates you and why you
here and yeah and then I'd know we'd
know exactly which areas of the world
life balance irrelevant mmm so you got
all these different things which are
brilliant like flexible working hours
and work from home and that but doesn't
matter I see what everyone yes
individual isn't I think that's the
thing for me yeah why why I see in
Commons I have it what live panel its
individual it's not like a blankie yeah
and I think as well you've got this
framework which is brilliant I might be
a bit naive it because I've not got a
business of 50 people but it's quite
easy to manage but we employ people that
understand that we're fair managers and
we do the best for each person so we
don't have anybody saying but why is
that person just laughed at for the
trust that we've done that for a reason
yeah so it might be that's important it
might be you know someone's just I don't
know not in the greatest place mentally
are you know something at home could
have happened others don't want to share
our stuff no the managers have made the
right call to say you don't need to come
in are just leave no one a question it
so it's got to be really specific and it
can't just be well it doesn't say in the
real book it doesn't say any contract so
you can't leave now yeah did you know
yeah I don't know of a staff
team that's 50 people so that must be a
lot more difficult to do but it's got to
be very bespoke I think right so what
I'd love to just get your perspective on
a few things as we but before we finish
so from your perspective now obviously
spoke about a lot about running the
business and your experience of that and
these sorts of things but in 2019 like
and your experience over the last sort a
couple years what what have you seen
they're sort of top performers in your
business do really well and what what do
you think contributes to that in today's
yeah top performers in your business
like what what common things that you
see in these people they know otherwise
why they're here okay and obviously your
top performers and you want them here
for a long time as well so and they know
exactly by the hair and what they're
doing it for if they're not going into
management why they're not going into
management why are you saying I'm
billing are going into management why
they're doing that
yeah not just copying the mayor yeah
you've done it progression and the go on
training yeah and I constantly
constantly develop in and so they don't
just leave the Bach in the drop yeah
yeah basic so flat really like every now
and again you're you're listening to a
top billing and you'll hear them you
hear them say something on the phone
that you know they've learned like a
month ago like yes straight away but the
dropping stuff in all the time are you
is it also common then that you're
sending these people always wanted to
learn yeah that's big hundred percent is
that the humility yeah
and you'll they'll learn in their own
time as well so it's hard to bring
changing and so you might change your
system or change a process or something
I think the top performers are the ones
that stop what they're doing listen to
what you're saying I have to headspace
to acknowledge it and then they'll
implement it over like a two-month
period and then in two months they're
starting to use this system really well
mm-hm
the ones that are lower performers
they're not listening they're not taking
on change you're getting with the times
they leave boxing drawers they don't
actually know how to use the new systems
you've put in and they getting left
behind a little bit and then it's always
a struggle and I'm the type of farmers
are the day plans if you were to look at
them they've gotten a lot of time for
for change an admin okay and take time
out of the day to learn when the
business is progressing and I see that
in the day plans only plan really well
because they do day plans
I'm really I'm really well so what does
that Dave plan every day really even if
it's a list of things today really yeah
so they'll just stop it tickler start it
could be time the top farmers always do
day plan yeah that's really practical
yeah no matter how long they've been
here have a yeah and I do day plans like
every day we're accountable to each
other okay yeah just so I know you
obviously mean you spoke about this when
I sort of starts learning a bit more
about your business and stuff but how
recent was it that you've changed it
where some people focused more on client
side and some people focused on delivery
time it was two years ago what was the
driver behind that so everyone listen
you've got a team that's dedicated on
crying so that their impairs a lot of
them happens got a mix of people so
firstly I lost a really good bill
because we didn't have a delivery model
and really good 360 guy but you wanted
to just focus on candidates okay he was
really good on the candidate side and he
was actually really good if you gave him
a job yeah and but just didn't really
enjoy any business lost that person went
on a training course had the trainer
said 360's dad and in four years you're
gonna be left behind like oh my god what
does this mean I only knew 360 so we
just started bringing it in
bit by bit Emma came off billing yeah
paired up with Mack
our contract Billa and they split it and
it was like ridiculous like the results
we got was so good and then I did loads
and loads of research on it and was like
Joe wah I don't want a company where
people are getting by an hour and
everyone that spoke to it was like so in
flow so I would if the inflow sort of
air theory and when you break it down
you like God Joe makes loads of sense
like you people who would be day you
need new business people out on the road
all the time bringing in new business
and then you've got the people who were
a bit more you know relationship side or
doing delivery and then you got you be
sources doing the candidate side and
everyone's doing what the good at what's
been the key million come free the
reason that yeah it's been the key to
that working do you think hire different
people for different roles so then show
us but so I think I've had one person
that really spoke a bit about this and
there's a guy called Nick so he's he's
from any worse for Finlay James
yeah and he's now in America but he
spoke about this and what he said was
really key and important that they had
to get right was the communication
between and the relationship between
their sort of the delivery person would
be a business person yeah but you said
pairs there that there must be reason
why you've done pairs and yeah sure you
can expect it to light you could have
one BD person and that may be to free
delivery people but the pet light is
that important yeah and we've we've had
like three sixties in place and then say
we got a CV that was spectin and they
were delivery and you know what we
interview you and you're just gonna go
really well with that person
yeah it's not really been planned out as
such for example we've just done it with
him Tom and Holly Holly was 360 doing
okay and she was like I do really want a
delivery person to progress the next
level and we've got Tom cv3
and we're like this just works yeah and
it was the match phone yeah it's not
been this big plan around so it's just
been like we need to be people all time
and if things work but a big fat sore as
to why Fink Billings of increases cetera
is as you said you've now got people in
roles where they're doing it's more
actually eight instead of yeah 5050
doing something
strongman fish yeah okay you've got
people like Apes and or whatever $0.75
doing what they're really good at really
good at yeah so you're not getting the
yo-yo yes I think which is where
everyone gets burnout and they go home
really depressed because they've got no
jobs on but then they can't get the time
how does that work commission wise it's
just split 50-50 is it yeah so when the
first come on it's in a 70/30 split yeah
because that person's teaching the
delivery person is usually a 360 teach
and a delivery and then once they're up
to speed it's a little team man and then
it's 50/50 always be there no so we got
taught that you should be 70% in flow so
70% every time is what you really good
at and if you 8% picking up the other
person's role and vice versa so for
example if you've got a team and DVDs on
holidays yeah delivery would still start
following your leads up and doing the BD
side but it's not forever
it's just picking each other's roles up
so we make sure they're competent and
each side of it and what the majority of
the time you 70% in your flow so 70%
candidates are 71b day yeah do you see
that yeah 360s like really good it's not
that easy to get people that have you're
very very good at that and so we've got
a real good mix in here we've got a few
360s we've got yeah resources coming
through and then we've got a delivery
team and then people doing B day our
team leaders yeah as we finish what are
you thinking about what you making sure
you do of your business to ensure you
evolve
stay stay relevant these lots of things
what do you think about going into next
year and one thing that learned from
Mike when I did that call with him
where's what she bought she value
proposition to your clients you come to
this and your staff yeah what like makes
you stand out and I'm really
articulating that some way making sure
like your brands out there and stuff as
we've been doing that for like the last
year so next year we want to make sure
we sort of really make sure that that's
communicated on linkedin obviously
help from you I think for me and
actually the brand is gonna be a big one
release we're at eighteen seventeen
eighteen we need to make sure that the
brands right so that we can go to that
next level believe that it's gonna be a
lot harder without it so yeah we need to
get that right what my optimized so II
like you speak to any Rock room yeah
we're different yeah you're right it's
like okay let's let's actually think
about that what makes you different yeah
and that doesn't mean it's not it's not
because you're a specialist no it needs
to be a bit more than that than that
it's gotta be really yes call me a room
I'm such a good boy it's gotta be really
real and to know why face I realized
that for me it was all about my staff
and that's fine
mmm-hmm and I don't know maybe maybe
some businesses think it's got to be
about the candidates are the clients
first but if it's not then it's not yeah
because for me the stuff of the the big
ones and then it alas I've filter
through to their clients anyway but I
think be honest with yourself and say
what it is and then maybe get some help
in putting that together somehow yeah so
just don't just copy what someone else
has done it's gotta be what making yeah
because people people can really feel
that when it's ruined yeah hundred
that's when it's really powerful yeah
work becomes a bit easier as well so
it's brand its I mean you really strike
me as something that's always willing to
learn yeah which i think is wicked and
which is wide two years ago you made the
decision to make a complete change and
yeah I think that I think that's so
important so I guess when I see that
you're someone that's very yeah you're
open-minded on how things can evolve
it's always thinking about how you can
improve and get better in these types of
things the video things the big one as
well video would you mean terrified of
it and what doing video videos and you
know all that type of stuff in him we've
been speaking about it for a long time
because we got loads of information from
the power hive in hidden stuff like that
but it's just making that change and
going right this is yeah this is gonna
change now in training people and is it
gonna work how clients gonna like it
and so that would be a huge thing if we
can get there next year and we're like
got a good present more importantly from
like buys into it and we get input with
ultimate yeah as you said for me it's
like yeah if you have that and then
you've got a team in here they're bloody
good yeah it's not a good at what they
do yeah that that is that is the
powerful really powerful combination do
you know I mean yeah okay well look
before we finish what are you excited
about what's what's going on in your
word that you want to shout about where
everyone goes now next year because
we've got such a good team and I know
everyone's got like such good you know
exciting plans like a you like buzzes
yeah like all of that sort of stuff
booking certain holidays or people
planning families that you know that
forgive some of us yeah it's nice to see
someone you know being recruitment and
they've got you know savings tip about
it I'm gonna yeah have a baby now and
the jobs but planning a like how we're
going to back fill that role whilst
they're Wayans to like sign so you
really owe a lot of stuff like that yeah
yeah yeah you said you obviously you
answer that were like yeah obviously but
yeah it can be quite typical where
someone is thinking trying about around
children family and they might want to
keep that sort of under wraps whatever
because the whole what's going for my
work whatever
yes seems like you're really really open
around we're planning yeah I think
that's great yeah we try to like we did
a bit gay meeting the other day actually
about this with the people that talking
about this in the next year after him
you know how we're going to support your
role what's gonna happen what your
clients with with him we've all you know
we've all got each other's back in that
sense so it's not about who just what
Bowl it's like everyone's there for each
other for that time in our life you know
yeah that's great yeah we try to like
have that size type of culture and but
yeah that I'm excited about that cuz
obviously be a lot of changing movement
is a guy getting married next year
a couple of really good strong billa's
that are brand new that gonna get houses
and stuff like that really yeah cool so
a question I asked everyone finish this
podcast so you can answer this with a
phrase a sentence whatever comes to mind
yeah so if you could communicate to
every single recruits out there that
take on an advisor said listen yeah
phrase sentence what comes to mind
what would you communicate to these
people the business but really important
it's like for anyone in recruitment if
you think you'd have to do kpi's and
something like right what are you saying
make sure that you know what activities
you yeah whatever you know always works
for you make sure you know what it is
and you do it yeah like it's huge it was
even like our top builders where they
know he's I thought they need to do and
we made sure it's only a few yeah no no
we need to do achieve a success you want
a more family Pete how many people know
that numbers I think that's great oh yes
I think a lot of people try and shy away
from it I think I want to be a business
no it's not KPI driven but I have kpi's
for myself like I don't know how you can
wear it without measurable targets and
stuff so and just know what even if it's
take two good things or just know what
it is what you are you go to it yeah
[Laughter]